[Music]
hey y'all
yep what's going on yeah we re-watched
this one last night
it just uh we saw it on it was available
on tubie right
yeah it was just like random i'd seen it
before like several years ago and you
had seen it before
yeah i liked it when i first saw it and
then we were just we were watching
something else on tubie and he's like
ooh look slither's on here so i was like
well we can watch that if you want
because i
we hadn't reviewed that one so i was
just like wait what decided to review on
so we decided to go ahead and like do a
matinee on it this is
uh a great movie uh it's so fun
yeah very fun movie it's a movie kind of
like
it's an alien movie alien invasion movie
falls to the earth kind of like on the
blob
um but it's also a little bit like the
thing
and uh would it be another this is
pretty much
and this got a lot of criticism from
horror fans when it came out like a lot
of people like this movie but they were
kind of like this is basically a
straight-up rip-off of knight of the
creeps from 1984.
yeah pretty much exactly the same thing
happens like aliens from space and
everything doesn't matter though but it
doesn't really matter because
i mean it's kind of has its own uh thing
to it
yeah it doesn't matter because it's fun
it's got a really good cast
the story's good nothing in it is real
um
groundbreaking like you said it's kind
of carbon copy
but the the writing the acting the tone
um
the humor in it is just good just it's
just a very enjoyable movie
um which it happens in it uh it's got
michael
uh rucker's in it michael rookers and uh
he's being mississippi as [ __ ]
is taking place it's supposed to be
north carolina north carolina
yeah i was wondering where the hell is
or south carolina yeah because
one of the carolinas the terrain
features look like it was a place up
north but everybody was speaking in
at least a fake southern accent some
more authentic than others
um had the guy from firefly he started
nathan
yeah he's my favorite character in it
and uh
and then michael rooker's wife's played
by a hot young thing what's her name
elizabeth banks
she's been in a [ __ ] ton of movies since
then she does a great job in it
it's kind of a it kind of rips on
on horror movie but it does take it
seriously too in a way but there's just
a lot of humor
it kind of pokes fun at
southern culture a little bit like every
you know i mean like you know
certain things in southern culture are
taken very seriously in this movie like
marriage
know it was just a bunch of [ __ ]
jokes on marriage
uh being a cop
uh just everything you know what i mean
it's just [ __ ] good movie
i liked it esther is asking about my
t-shirt um is it available for sale
actually we didn't make this one this i
got this one at the ripley's believe it
or not museum
in st augustine it's a voodoo shirt i
just got it in the gift shop
yeah at the ripley's museum it's got a
nice set of boobs in it too
well sure that goes i polish the top of
them so you get a better reflection
rainbow cast off that's [ __ ] good
luck yeah yeah
boob prisms yeah it makes money like
that
i wish i wish it made money
that'd be so cool if like i could have a
prism rainbow like bouncing off my boob
and then at the end was like a pot of
gold like a leprechaun
awesome i know that'd be but there's a
lot of a lot of stuff in it
a lot of stuff in this movie if you
haven't seen it you should see it it's
it's it's i don't know they came out in
the 2000s
2006 that came out yeah which was kind
of like a
cookie cutter type of a movie for 2006
but it's kind of aged into a little
classic
the thing about that here's what's
really interesting um in case you guys
didn't know this was actually
james gunn's first uh directorial debut
uh obviously he went on to much greater
fame he directed
the guardians of the galaxy movies he
did suicide squad [ __ ] like that
but before he did this movie he was
actually like a screenwriter and he
worked on a lot of troma movies i think
his first screenwriting credit might
have been romeo and juliet if i'm not
mistaken
yeah so he's kind of like a horror guy
yeah now the interesting thing about
this is that
so on the back of some of the [ __ ] that
he had done like in his screenwriting
career they decided they'll give him you
know the boilerplate
15 million or whatever like the studio
that made it
and this movie did uh it pretty much
flopped
like it like it made some money but not
enough to make its production budget
back
and the shitty thing i was watching
something um
ryan hollinger who's this really great
like irish guy and he he did like kind
of a real in-depth uh
look at this movie because he's like a
big fan of it and you know he thinks it
kind of got shafted which it sort of did
because a lot of people didn't see it it
got really well reviewed
but for some reason like audiences just
weren't down for it
he thought yeah he thought maybe it was
because he's like
there weren't a lot of other horror
comedies out at the time
uh sean of the dead had come out like
two years before which was a big success
but there wasn't really a lot of other
ones and
he's like the early 2000s were kind of
all horror remakes
um a lot of which did really well like
you know the dawn of the dead remake
which i think james gunn also worked on
um you know the hills have eyes remake
like all the and so he's like it was
either
remakes or torture porn or kind of like
supernatural horror there weren't like a
lot of other horror comedies out and
maybe just people weren't in the mood
for it
things go in and out of style yeah
that's what it is it must have just been
timing
yeah i mean the thing kind of flopped
yeah you know
john carpenter's the thing if a gazanna
just saw it for the first time last
night he's [ __ ] he messaged me he's
like man this movie's good man it's
really good he says the acting's great
yeah and it was the same thing and i
think because the thing
kind of flopped and it had to go up
against e.t that summer
um i think that kind of [ __ ] broke
john carpenter's spirit i mean it's
[ __ ]
because that's a masterpiece that thing
is a masterpiece especially in its day
you know what i mean that was cutting
edge science well [ __ ] and people are
still watching that [ __ ]
nowadays it's like it aged really well
so yeah even the sequel is pretty good
i mean so just because something didn't
do that well the box office at the time
doesn't mean anything doesn't mean
anything and
i think this is definitely one that um
you know
it really didn't do very well at the
time but i think as time has gone on has
been very kind to it
and honestly when we watched it again
last night like the special effects and
everything like that have aged really
well
i mean i think it looks real a lot of
them are practical there is some cgi
but it actually the cgi still looks uh
pretty good yeah and
the mixture of cgi and practical works
real well i like that
because the cg is just for tentacles and
certain things that they did sparingly
but it had good practical effects
and when the alien starts growing up on
the walls and it takes more space as it
starts to consume more stuff
and the woman who is pregnant carrying
all the damn little [ __ ] slugs and
[ __ ]
it you can tell it's really there yeah
and it looks great
you know and it i just think it's a good
movie just a good script
yeah it's just a super super fun movie
now um
you know i think it was mango that said
uh earlier that
uh yeah mango said i think shauna the
dead is the better of those two movies i
would agree with you i do think shauna
the dead is better funnier
um this one is a little bit different
and i feel like maybe sean of the dead
benefited from everybody being zombie
crazy
this one was not really it had like some
zombie movie sort of elements but this
one was more like a monster movie like
an alien
invasion more type of more like the blob
yeah this was more yeah
like the blob like i said or like knight
of the creeps or something yeah and well
i haven't seen that one
yeah that was from 84. the alien is more
like the cross between the blob and the
thing
and zombies kinda and i like that they
made the alien like a hive mind it's a
hive mind
so it was really just one alien even
there's like a whole bunch of slugs
well the thing is kind of a high of mine
too that's true um or you assume
because they act in concert and you
can't tell where the thing ends or
begins you know
little ones and big ones and they can
merge and then they can split so it's
like that
because they weren't merging they were
splitting too
yeah but it and it did do pretty cool
[ __ ] it was morphing over time but not
as quickly as say like
the thing the thing could just become
whatever it needed right away
yeah you know what i mean because uh
when rooker was being taken over and
changing
the change wasn't that drastic over over
a long period of time yeah it took a
long time for him to change
yeah days you know it's almost yeah it's
almost kind of like the alien had a
certain life cycle because
you know whatever it was it landed on
you know a ship or a
meteor or whatever it was and then
michael rooker finds it out in the woods
and it looked kind of like a gooey
um yeah what do you call it i i assume
it fell as like a meteor
yeah i think it was because like yeah
there was that shot where they were like
in the car and like something fell like
a meteor
well and actually at the beginning they
showed like the meteor like hurdles yeah
it was in a meteor yeah
so it comes directly it's realistic
that's right how something would come
it's just an alien life form
on a meteor yeah it had been around for
billions of years and it had
memories yeah of where it had been
which i liked that aspect of it but if
it merged with you it became you too
yeah so you were kind of a mixture of
the alien because he's still remembered
and he wouldn't remember his wife
yeah and he still remembered his wife
and it was still like he was still able
to feel human emotions and stuff
and some of the funniest part too was
when the other people like when he
impregnates
uh you know brenda and she like blows up
in the into the womb the womb turned her
into a woman and then when she explodes
and all the [ __ ]
all the [ __ ] slugs go everywhere um
and then it starts taking over all the
townsfolk
all the townsfolk are chasing after
starla
um you know because that's like michael
rooker's wife's character yeah and he's
so
so they all like have the same memories
of her yeah so i guess the first person
infected
becomes the king of the hive mind for
that yeah yeah yeah
because nobody else had any real control
they were around but my
but the michael rooker's character could
take over their personalities remotely
yeah whenever he wanted to he could jump
through everybody
and that's and that was another thing
too and we mentioned that was like
something that's kind of better than a
zombie movie because if
one of the townsfolk like that was
possessed saw you they everything
everybody saw you so everybody knew
where you were because everyone was like
one mind
if it took over a planet there'd be no
escape because you couldn't fight one
and get away with it
all the other ones wouldn't no just jump
on you would all [ __ ] the whole world
would come in on you
so it would take over a planet pretty
quickly which that's what would happen
with the thing too
well yeah and we've talked about that
before like if like if something like
the thing
landed on earth we would be [ __ ] toast
be no stopping it
would be [ __ ] big time yeah you
couldn't stop it nope
and the thing would have been a little
more dangerous because it would
it could accurately mimic a person
yeah the only way is it couldn't mimic
your jewelry or your
your like earrings and it couldn't mimic
uh
fillings yeah but like you'd have to be
pretty on the ball like down the ball
and you could walk in you know like a
person that you know
and then kill you and then take you over
well and that's exactly what happened in
the movie like yeah
flick [ __ ] comes out of their face and
everything like that i know this one's
like it it's just the tone is very
different
it's a little more it's a lot more
playful um
uh it's it has horror elements it has a
lot of action in it
but it's it kind of takes its subject
matter seriously
but it all but the characters are very
humorous yeah definitely a comedy i like
that it's like really gory and goopy
and it has like a lot of like you said
it has like some scary [ __ ] in it
because if you think about the
implications of it it's like a pretty
terrifying
thing but i really like i and the humor
comes
from the reactions of the characters to
it because they don't really know
what to make of this well yeah and like
they act the way like a normal people
would act like they're just kind of
cracking jokes because they don't know
what else to do this is like the
craziest [ __ ] [ __ ] they've ever seen
yeah and so i mean and nathan fillion is
so like i love him and everything
like i'm a big fan of firefly and stuff
and so
just his deadpan kind of like he's when
he first sees like the michael rooker
like the monster like the final form
with all the
that i said it looks like the shunting
like from society
where they're all like stuck together
and he's just kind of looking at it
going well now there's some [ __ ] up
[ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah it's just like
so [ __ ] great
and i thought what i liked was like the
uh the relationship between michael
rooker and his wife
rooker's looking good he's about 50
something in it he's in real good shape
uh it must be on that damn juice i don't
know
but he's rich he's got this big house
and he married this fine young thing was
much younger than him probably by
20 30 years 20 years maybe yeah
something like something like that
and uh she was from she was she was from
the trailers
and uh her parents died so it kind of
left her petting lists
so he scooped her up when she was young
and sent her to college i think
they scooped up when she was 17. yeah
something yeah yeah yeah that's right
so she comes back and she's kind of like
the town [ __ ]
teacher she's like super hot and all the
[ __ ] teenage boys are [ __ ]
drooling
so they threw that in there that's good
but because it's southern culture she
takes
she you know she she loves him i i think
she does but i think she's also kind of
sick of him
um because she she got she got tired of
sleeping with him so he went down to
uh to the bar and met up with another
one who was a little bit older but hot
too
and she had a crush on him when she was
a girl
and they go off to go make out and then
he decides that he's not going to do her
yeah he's going to be true because he's
a he's a good guy he's a good dude yeah
he decides he's not going to do it yeah
but then they find the damn asteroid
thing and he immediately gets
impregnated it jumps down and it
bores into it like shoots a little
needle hooks up with his brain
and then it turns on her and he
impregnates her turns her into a womb
that's the [ __ ] with his [ __ ] the
tentacles that come out of his stomach
and like go into herself
don't blame me darling it's just my
nature you know and [ __ ] like that you
know it's just
i mean him going to the [ __ ] grocery
store and just sitting there going
he's collecting all the dead dogs and
cows and everything and feeding it to
the girls
she's chained to the wall getting bigger
and bigger and bigger just turns into a
fat round ball
i'm so hungry i'm so [ __ ] hungry hand
me that possum over there
these bastards are tearing me apart oh
it looks creepy man
that [ __ ] [ __ ] exploded yeah
it's good it's so gooey this movie is so
gooey i love it though
yeah but rooker [ __ ] goes back to his
rookers goes back to his wife and she's
seen he looks sick he's saying it's just
a bee sting
that's just a bee sting darling doctor
gave me something my mom would be all
right
he's going out [ __ ] noodles kind of
[ __ ] and uh
yeah yeah i liked it she uh
she in the end she you know she realizes
he's a [ __ ] monster
but she's like i'm gonna stay true to
your darling just like i said she's
trying to save the marriage and [ __ ]
it's [ __ ] funny
well i think she was trying to get close
enough to him to like kill him because
yeah by the time that ended but early on
you know what i mean before she saw him
cut that dude in half she was trying to
yeah you know which is also she was
trying to save the marriage and [ __ ]
yeah because that dude was all trying to
like drop his nuts and everything
you better stop sitting like that in the
[ __ ] tentacles
intestines going everywhere so awesome
honestly i have to say
one of my favorite scenes in this wasn't
even like all the gore is great like
everybody's great in this
one of my favorite scenes is when like
the first time
after they see him and they just kind of
see him from far away so they kind of
see like the tentacle action a little
bit
but everyone's still kind of making
jokes about it and they're all like in
the um
in the uh police station and they have
and they put the little that little
stuffed squid like on the dude's
computer
and [ __ ] like that and he's like just
this isn't funny what the [ __ ]
and then like when it when they're
trying to figure out like where he's
gonna hit next and they have these
little squid stickers
like from where it's just like [ __ ] like
that was like so funny because i love
that like kind of
con's never seen slither man you gotta
see it oh thank you no need for me too
okay finally made it missed you guys in
the chat peeps yeah thank you um i want
to say like a leia's here too
okay yeah yeah yeah we're gonna go see
uh
we're gonna go see the uh concert next
week starry night
starry night on saturday night you guys
better get i know i'm excited i haven't
seen them in our really yeah i don't
know if you guys ever been to will's pub
but will's pub's
good around here yeah i like it there
good for live music and beer beer and
live music
what else do you like about life
kind of like it's an irish pub it's kind
of like a place where you see puck rock
bands and stuff
yeah all kind of bands played there you
know they do yeah but it'd be like a
good place to see like it's like rock
management it's like stuff with like
posters and memorabilia stuff all over
the wall
and filthy bathrooms and you know it's
super fun it's like that
yeah it's like how it moves yeah it's
like that because it's like old pinball
machines and [ __ ] like that
yeah that's fine but yeah so it's like
little scenes like that
that are like what's super funny to me
like
all like and the whole [ __ ] with um
what's her name uh
that actress that was in the office that
played pam what the hell is her name she
was married to james gunn at this time
so
i think she was in a bunch of his movies
and she has like a really small part in
this like she's like the dispatcher
at the police station and she's like
talking to him over the thing and she's
like
all it's in here is the skeeter is like
around and whatever
and then like he asked her a question
she's nodding into the radio
and he's like are you nodding there's
all kinds of good humor and everything
like teasing that one cop because she
was a lesbian if she wasn't a lesbian
she
got married to michael ricker rich guy
yeah remember that
and i mean and the the guy that plays
the mayor
in this oh he's a douchebag oh my god
he's so [ __ ] funny like that [ __ ]
freak out he has at the end he's like
you know people like driving my people
around like skinned cars and like
there's no mr pibb in the [ __ ] cooler
and he's just like having a [ __ ] wig
out
but the cool thing about this is that
even though he's a [ __ ]
he's still like a good like a likeable
character
you know what i mean like everybody in
this is a likable
character yeah it's they're just kind of
riffing on small towns
america in the south jenna fischer thank
you that was that's
his name it's like a small town south
you know yeah and
it's pretty stereotypical it's about
what it's like it's poking fun at it but
it's not disrespecting it
it's just that's what i mean it's poking
fun but it's like affectionately poking
fun
yeah you know what i mean which which
like i said that's kind of a hard line
to
draw a lot of people in the movie you're
southerners yeah well yeah that too yeah
so
there's probably that whole thing so
yeah he's not like he's not making fun
of them
it's just kind of like there are
idiosyncrasies in southern culture
and everybody in this is like i said
even the people that
even michael rooker's character who in a
lot of movies they would just make him a
bad guy
he's a good guy he's a good you know he
deep down he's a good guy he's got like
flaws but
everybody in this has flaws but they're
still like likable people
he loved his wife he could have cheated
on her and he said no i'm not going to
yeah and then the monster guy and then
he got merged with the monster
yeah yeah and it it's nature over
overrode his but he remembered
his wife it's just that that wouldn't
and he was really really trying not to
hurt her
right because he remembered her but he
was like how can you blame a man for
following his nature
because your nature changes as soon as
you you know
become one with this monster but it's
good it's kind of like the thing
that kinda yeah like a like a fun
comedic
version of that yeah and you know but it
had some [ __ ]
scary [ __ ] in it too you know i mean
like when she got turned into the womb
when i first saw that that was very
disturbing it it's quite an image
oh yeah yeah she's just like a face like
sticking out yeah and she wanted to eat
them dead animals
[Laughter]
yeah and everybody yeah and like i said
there is a lot of disturbing imagery
there's a lot of gore in those people
getting their heads blown off with
shotguns
yeah and then uh her husband becomes
this big
mass of other people who are trying to
join in with him in his damn tentacles
that way he could gain more mass he
didn't have to work out to gain mass he
would just
absorb infected people they'd walk into
him yeah they'd
be like bigger and bigger we're we're
going into the collective yeah that's
weird going into like a collective
like i said it was like the shunting
yeah if you guys have not seen society
we did a review of that a while back but
that's
that's what that end monster like
reminded me of and they did the
gun he knew he knew well enough to
[ __ ] do the old
uh cute teenager in the bathtub scene
yeah
yeah and then the [ __ ] thing goes in
there like a sperm like it's going in
between her legs
and then it jumped into her mouth and
she was trying to keep it from getting
into her mouth
and for a second she saw
the memories of the collective of how it
got here and where it came from the
other planets that it absorbed what
it was absorbing little mice creatures
yeah it was weird yeah so that was good
that she you that you had that character
because her whole
family including the little children uh
got taken over taken over
and they were trying to kill her yeah
but so yeah so she had an insight into
what the alien was and where it came
from and she was the one that said you
know probably if we kill
michael rooker's character who's his
character's name is grant grant
yeah great just grandpa yeah well that
was his first day madison
grant grant well some southerners didn't
do that man
that's yeah that's that's uh yeah that
checks out
[Laughter]
but yeah so like i said we just watched
this i thought it was funny because
somebody mentioned earlier
that um that they had just watched this
randomly last night and i was like hey
so did we
we totally did not plan to watch this we
were just watching something else on to
be like for the movie retrospective
and tom was just like hey they have
slither on here and i was like hey let's
watch that i haven't seen it alone
was probably suggesting it to everybody
who had us
maybe they just added it because like a
lot of times they'll you know because
they add
when they add new [ __ ] they'll put
everything yeah cod if you haven't seen
slither man check it out
it's super fun it's like like i said
it's not you know a
[ __ ] masterpiece of cinema or
anything like that but it's just a fun
alien invasion monster movie
yeah uh it's a comedy it knows what it
is yeah it's not trying to be something
it isn't and it's just trying to be like
super entertaining and it just keeps
going there's no
slow parts really um i kind of feel like
once
once they've established everyone's
characters at the beginning it just kind
of like goes into
him turning into a monster and like
eating cows and whatnot yeah the edit
and kind of the speed or the tempo of
the movie reminded me a lot of the blob
yeah watching the blob yeah either the
original or the
or the even the remakes a good remake of
the blob it's
that same kind of just keep moving
forward fast
i want to actually see the 80s remake of
the blob because i remember that being
uh actually pretty [ __ ] good yeah i
remember liking i haven't seen it
i remember liking it a lot yeah and um
and i've seen like subsequently
i remember like seeing like scenes from
it and other reviews out and i'm like
goddamn i need to rewatch that because i
remember that being really really good
yeah like way better than a remake of a
cheesy 50s movie
movie had any right to be um but yeah
tasha bella said the slugs reminded her
of uh shivers the david cronenberg
movie yeah which yeah they were like
very kind of similar so like i said this
is
he's making homages to lots of other
horror movies
yeah you know what i mean he's not like
ripping anything off exactly but it's
just
they played the original blob on
television when i was a little kid i
must have been about seven or eight yeah
that [ __ ] and it scared the [ __ ] out of
me well there's something
really yeah there's some really like
disturbing
imagery in that eating that dude up and
then you see him fighting us trying to
get it get out of the damn
window through the venetian blinds at
the doctor's office yeah i remember when
you go in there and he's just a damn
blob and it totally absorbed him yeah
[ __ ] where you know i was like whoa
it was scary like six seven years old
because the way the edit is and the
dialogue is so simple a seven or eight
year old can follow it
real well yeah and it's not a tired
genre or a tired theme it's the first
time you've seen it
the concept of being eaten up by a damn
alien that
organism like an amoeba that fell in on
an asteroid
yeah i mean that's gonna be some pretty
like horrifying [ __ ] that one and the
original 1950s war of the worlds
[ __ ] really uh captivated
my imagination yeah i love the war of
the worlds i haven't seen that in a long
time
the original one the original with the
damn boomerang
ships yeah on the anti-gravity [ __ ]
suspension
legs and the [ __ ] remember the little
[ __ ]
it had like a like a like a cobra
neck that came out of there with an
electric eye that would look go into the
houses and
shoot the heat rays and
man it tripped me out when they came out
of the damn impact zone and that priest
says let me go
reason with these aliens and then
[ __ ] they they zapped that priest
yeah i saw that when i saw that [ __ ]
happened i was like oh
no oh you can't reason with them they
don't even believe in god
you can't believe you can't you can't
reason with these aliens yeah
yeah well yeah i mean that's how i took
it they'd even kill the damn priest
[ __ ] dastardly [ __ ]
they were here to annihilate everything
and they would annihilate the dogs and
all the animals and all the damn cows
and [ __ ]
yeah see now that's where i draw the
line like i said
yeah that's my horror movie rules it's
like you can kill all the people you
want but leave the little i got to see
that leave the little kitties and
doggies alone they didn't hurt anybody
yeah i got to see that one again
wasn't wasn't a little girl wasn't a
little boy or a little girl running
carrying a cat or a dog
to safety and she was in a crowd and it
just
and it wiped out the entire i think so i
haven't seen that a lot of times i've
seen it i was i was thinking of that
movie that really terrible like 50s
movie that was on mst teenagers from
outer space
yeah and like the teenagers from outer
space who were actually like 45 years
old
yeah but they all kind of came here with
like the [ __ ] jumpsuits and whatnot
and they had a skeletonizing
gun so they would just like shoot you
with a gun and it turned you into a
skeleton yeah i remember that
and they did it to a dog first i
remember the dog's name was sparky
yeah and they found like sparky's
skeleton later like with his little tag
that said sparky on it i even liked the
tom cruise uh war of the worlds
it was that right it was okay they could
have done more with it but they didn't
um yeah yeah i wish they would have done
a little bit more the whole idea that
they came out of the ground and they
were down there for millions of years
now that was stupid
they actually literally should have come
from mars underneath the surface of mars
that's where they should have come yeah
i mean i think feel like that probably
would have been more believable yeah it
didn't make any sense that they were
because they're like they lived way
under the
you know under the surface of mars so we
didn't see it
yeah i mean you know because that that
could totally happen well i mean it's
believable enough for a science major
for a science fiction movie
you know i know everyone's more
sophisticated nowadays can't get away
with the [ __ ] they used to be able to
get away with back in the old days
i would have said that they were down
inside the core near the core of mars
you know they had a huge city down there
and they had to leave
that they had been building that armada
for tens of thousands
of years but i guess people would have
said well they would have won
well yeah yeah that's what what's what
are really what happened
that's kind of i feel like that's kind
of a fatal flaw in a lot of sci-fi
movies especially nowadays like any
any sufficiently evolved
species or that was you know that can
come here that could come here that had
technology to come here would probably
just like wipe us out without us even
knowing that we
they were up there well that's why i
liked the thing the thing could have
easily wiped
out the entire earth and it came here in
a spacecraft
it's just that it by chance landed on in
antarctica and got frozen yeah so it
couldn't get
it couldn't it's like our navigation was
a little [ __ ] up we thought that maybe
[Laughter]
well there's no there's no there's no
proof
that that that spaceship was
made by the thing maybe it infected that
spaceship
oh yeah i guess i guess that would be
well it was just kind of like
um it's just kind of like was the one
that we watched the other day the
tomorrow war
where it's just like the alien that was
taken over there they didn't actually
build that ship they just came here
they came here as like cargo inside the
ship so they didn't
actually build the ship right so so i
thought that was a good way out of it so
like you said that might have
the the thing that was the thing that
doesn't necessarily mean that they
crash steered that ship might have
crashed because they got out
and attacked that idea i like that idea
better yeah it's probably what it
happened
because it's like maybe those aliens
were coming here to be all like peace
and love and everything like that and
then like the thing got on there like
was like a hitchhiker
and i was like [ __ ] all you guys well it
it obviously crashed there because it
was all
[ __ ] up the ship although it tried to
leave in it later
in the in in the 2011 one we're
dissecting the wrong movie
okay uniform that happens every single
time yeah
that happens every single time in the
2011 thing you see the ship again
it i i guess it was its ship it was
filled with a bunch of tubes
yeah you know what i mean the corridors
were just two series of tubes
and uh yeah the computer's graphics
screens with just a bunch of damn
levitating blocks
merging and flipping over didn't make
any sense to a human
at least the human eye it's pretty cool
wouldn't it be funny if that was like
the alien equivalent of like a
screensaver
yeah we're all like trying to figure out
like what the [ __ ] does that mean
they're like nothing man we just put it
on there to keep the face it looked like
a dna molecule yeah
suspended doing something moving around
that it wouldn't make any sense to us
you know
that's like or it was the alien
equivalent of like a lava lamp
yeah yeah and we're all like trying to
like attribute meaning to it and stuff
yeah that's if i was making a sci-fi
movie that's what i would do
i would put all this [ __ ] in there that
looked all like high-tech and we were
trying to figure it out and it turned
out it was just like some [ __ ] that
didn't although the damage on the thing
may have happened when that when the
when the when the norwegians blew it up
out of the ice because i think it was in
good condition in the 2011 one yeah
because that was a prequel right
right so it must have landed it and then
fell asleep in there frozen on purpose
maybe because uh
i don't know maybe it was so long ago
there wasn't any humans there to absorb
there's some reason only the aliens
would know
maybe they have some reason that we
can't even fathom
yeah might have been hiding out from the
cops
[Laughter]
i turned over a liquor store i got to go
into hiding
it might have been a fugitive i had to
hide
oh my god hey anything's possible right
well yeah that's what i mean
it's just you know and i i wonder how
many of these possibilities have been
explored in sci-fi fiction in movies
that i haven't seen i'm sure probably
might have been something that escaped
it had to hide so it just
it could travel through space but not
time so it said [ __ ] i'm asleep for 10
000 years and they'll all be dead by the
time i get up
yeah might have been something like that
by the time i get up
that's what the aliens from prometheus
would do yeah they'd just get in the
damn sleep chamber and [ __ ] sleep you
to death
[Laughter]
i get out in 2 000 years you should i
can wait
it'll just seem like a second to me i'll
just like fall asleep and then i'll wake
up it'll be two thousand kill all you
[ __ ]
yeah but with old age yeah
that's the lazy way to do it yeah kind
of smart when you think about it well
yeah that's what i mean just just cause
just because it's the lazy way yeah like
this just sucks i'm gonna sleep for
about 2000 years this will all be a bad
memory by then
yeah i mean yeah you can't fight a
[ __ ] when he's
when you can't find him and he's asleep
you can't even can't even mess with his
[ __ ] state of calm
yeah yeah all right so yeah i guess uh
she said that she had just seen uh toby
had just added it so i guess that's why
it came up in the recommendations
because like i said pretty much all i
watch on toby is horror movie so that's
always gonna come up
first so uh so yeah if you haven't seen
it a little bit i kind of feel like it's
got
um you know a cult following now
but it's still like a little bit
underrated i feel like i don't
see i don't really hear that many people
talking about it and it's actually
really really
fun like if you like horror comedies and
all you know
gore and [ __ ] like that uh anything else
you would like to
add nope all right so i guess what's
today monday
yeah it's monday yeah all right so we
will watch whatever movie we
figure out later we don't have a plan
we'll watch something later and we'll
talk about it yes the 2b version seemed
to be unedited
yeah i don't i didn't uh there was
nothing missing out of there it was it
was gory and all the swearing was there
and
i didn't think there was i don't i
didn't remember there being much nudity
i think there was like
there was like a flash and nip of like
the teenage girl on the tub but i don't
i don't remember any other nudity being
in the theatrical version
so i i know it's weird because i i
mentioned this on our
review that's coming out later this week
it's like one of the movies we watched
on there
had like some of the nudity was
pixelated and i thought that was really
strange because i'd never seen that on
tv before 2b doesn't generally cut the
movies
so i don't know if they got their hands
on some weird
cut and didn't notice or i don't really
know but yeah so
we will be back uh tomorrow at 3 p.m
talking about
another movie uh that we'll find out
what it is
when you guys do and uh thanks everybody
for
dropping by and we'll talk to you guys
again tomorrow
bye